SOME ISIS LINK ACCOUNT CELEBRATE
THAT ATTACK.
>> FOX NEWS NATIONAL SECURITY
STRATEGIST AND FORMER DEPUTY
ASSISTANT TO THE
IT'S INTERESTING EVERY TIME.
WHAT DID WE LEARN THAT THE
COMMUNIST MAYOR OF NEW YORK GAVE
BELIEVED THREE ATTACKS.
AND WE GO BACK TO THE ISSUE OF
IMMIGRATION AND WE GO BACK TO
THE PRESIDENT HAVING THE FIGHT
IN THE COURT SO WE CAN BET
PEOPLE THAT COME FROM COUNTRIES
THAT DO NOT SHARE OUR VALUES AND
IT KEEPS COMING UP EVERY ATTACK.
AND YET THE LEFT STILL SUPPORT
THESE POLICIES.
IT'S HARD TO UNDERSTAND.
>> IT TRULY IS.
THEY SHOULD HAVE SURPRISED
COMPLETELY BANKRUPT.
THE LAST NEW YORK ATTACKER
MANAGED TO SPONSOR MORE THAN 20
PEOPLE IN CHAIN MIGRATION INTO
THE UNITED STATES.
THIS WAS ALSO A PERSON WHO CAME
IN THROUGH THE CHAIN MIGRATION.
I JUST ARRIVED YESTERDAY BACK
FROM AUSTRALIA.
AUSTRALIA FOR EXAMPLE HAS A
COMPLETELY MERIT-BASED
IMMIGRATION SYSTEM AND
COMING TO THIS COUNTRY.
YOU CONTRIBUTE TO THIS COUNTRY
AND ARE YOU A THREAT.
WHY CAN'T AMERICA HAVE A SYSTEM
>> Sean: IF PEOPLE ARE CAUGHT
ENTERING AUSTRALIA ILLEGALLY --
LET'S SAY THEY ARE IN A BOAT.
AUSTRALIA IS VERY COMPASSIONATE.
CAN GET BACK TO THEIR
SOMEBODY IS SICK, THEY WON'T
EVEN TAKE THEM INTO THE COUNTRY.
THEY WILL TAKE THEM TO A
SEPARATE ISLAND AND TAKE CARE OF
THEM.
BUT YOU ARE RIGHT.
IF WE OPEN OUR BORDERS
COMPLETELY WE COULD PICK AND
CHOOSE.
EVERYBODY WOULD WANT TO COME
HERE.
THE BEST, THE BRIGHTEST
CONTRIBUTORS THAT WOULD MAKE
SOCIETY BETTER, THAT DON'T HAVE
VALUES THAT CONTRADICT OUR
VALUES.
WHY IS THAT SO COMPLICATED?
HOW DOES THAT GET SO POLITICIZED
HOW DOES THAT GET SO POLITICIZE
POLITICIZED?
>> LOOK, THE FACT IS THE LEFT
HAS TRIED TO SELL A BILL OF
GOODS WHERE THEY SAY EVERYBODY
HAS THE RIGHT TO COME TO AMERICA
HAS THE RIGHT TO COME TO AMERIC
AMERICA.
IT'S INSANITY.
MEANING.
REMEMBER WHAT HILLARY DID.
WHERE SHE SAID THERE SHOULD BE
NO BORDERS IN THE WESTERN
HEMISPHERE HE FROM CANADA ALL
THE WAY DOWN, NO BORDERS.
IF THAT WERE THE CASE, IF SHE
WOULD HAVE WON, AMERICA WOULD
HAVE CEASED TO EXIST AS A
CONCEPT AND WE WOULD BE HAVING
ATTACKS OCCURRING EVERY COUPLE
OF DAYS.
>> Sean: LET ME SHIFT GEARS,
LET ME GO TO THE ISSUE OF ALL OF
THESE FAKE NEWS REPORTS THAT I
LAID OUT IN MY OPENING MONOLOGUE
TONIGHT.
WE HAVE KNOWN A LONG TIME THAT
REAL JOURNALISM IS DEAD IN THE
COUNTRY.
I SAID THAT IN '07-08.
BUT THE AGENDA OF THE MEDIA NOW.
THEY ARE ACTIVELY TRYING TO
UNDERMINE AND UNSEAT AND
HOW SHOULD THE PRESIDENT DEAL
WITH IT?
>> WE HAVE A DEADLY COMBINATION.
YOUR MONOLOGUE WAS SPOT ON.
THE LEFT HAS CREATED A WEB.
I HATE CONSPIRACY THEORIES, BUT
IF YOU LOOK AT WHAT THE MEDIA IS
DOING.
IF YOU LOOK AT HOW THINGS LIKE
THE FBI HAVE BECOME POLITICIZED.
NOBODY IS GETTING IN TROUBLE IN
THE FBI FOR HAVING REPUBLICAN
VIEWS.
WHAT'S HAPPENING?
THEY ARE DEMOCRATS.
THEY HAVE BEEN IN CONTRAVENTION,
THEY HAVE GIVEN HILLARY
TREATMENT FOR THINGS THAT WOULD
HAVE SENT YOU OR I TO PRISON.
HOW DO WE RESPOND?
LEADERSHIP, AND WE HAVE TO DRAIN
THE SWAMP.
THE PRESIDENT HAS TO DRIVE THE
PEOPLE WITH POLITICAL AGENDAS
OUT OF GOVERNMENT BECAUSE IF YOU
ARE A BUREAUCRAT, YOUR POLITICS
SHOULD BE A PRIVATE AFFAIR, THEY
SHOULDN'T AFFECT POLICY.
IN THE MEDIA -- LOOK, I HOPE
IT'S GOING TO BE MARKET FORCES.
WE WERE CRUSHING IT ON CABLE
NEWS.
YOU ARE NUMBER ONE.
AS LONG AS THE MARKET FORCES
DICTATE THINGS LIKE CNN WILL
BECOME IRRELEVANT SOONER OR
LATER.
>> Sean: I THINK SOMEBODY
I DON'T KNOW IF THAT STILL TRUE
BUT THAT WAS TRUE AT THE TIME.
KNOW THAT HE HAS CLINTON LOVERS,
TRUMP HATERS.
EXCULPATORY INFORMATION TO
DEFENDANTS.
NOW THAT ALL HAVE ONE AGENDA.
WHAT IS THE ANSWER IN YOUR MIND,
BECAUSE I DON'T SEE AN EASY
ANSWER TO UNTANGLE THE MESS OF
POLITICS NOW THAT HAS CORRUPTED
THAT SPECIAL COUNSEL.
>> Sean: LET ME REMIND YOUR
AUDIENCE AND LET ME REMIND THE
DNC, THE CHIEF LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICER OF THE UNITED STATES
ACCORDING TO THE U.S.
ATTORNEY GENERAL.
THE CHIEF LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICER IS THE PRESIDENT, AND
RIGHT NOW THAT'S JUMBLED SO
McDONALD JAY TERM.
HE COULD FIRE MUELLER LEGALLY
TOMORROW IF HE SO WISHED BUT HE
WOULD HAVE TO BE BACKED UP BY
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY.
WE NEED TO SEE LEADERSHIP FROM
CAPITOL HILL THAT UNDERSTANDS --
>> Sean: WHY DOESN'T JEFF
VERY DIFFICULT PLACE WITH HIS
VERY, VERY ILL-ADVISED DECISION
TO RECUSE HIMSELF FROM THE
RUSSIA INVESTIGATION.
HE CAN REASSERT HIS POWER AS THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL, BUT WE ALSO
HAVE TO SEE A BROADER SUPPORT
FROM CONGRESS FOR THE PRESIDENT,
HIS AGENDA AND WHAT NOVEMBER THE